Таким образом, мы наблюдаем, что чем ближе человек относится к кому-то,
кто страдает шизофренией
Более вероятно, что этот человек также страдает расстройством.
Поэтому мы знаем из этого, что существует генетический компонент для шизофрении, но сам по себе этого недостаточно .
но сам по себе этого недостаточно .
There also has to be some kind of
stressful environmental experience
that the person suffers from.
Those two things together are really
what's required and we refer to this
as the diathesis stress model.
So, diathesis means
the biological predisposition
and the stress means some kind
of environmental event.
It's those two things together
that are really required.
And this, by the way, applies to all kinds
of psychological disorders.
Anxiety, personality disorders,
obsessive compulsive disorders.
So, let's take a closer look at some
of the seenvironmental risk factors
for schizophrenia.
So one of the risk factors involved
in the development of schizophrenia
is maternal infection.
And so what we mean by this is that
if a pregnant woman is exposed to diseases
or infections, that the baby, later on
in life, actually has an increased risk
for the development of schizophrenia.
So some of these diseases and infections
include things like herpes,
influenza, rubella and toxoplasmosis.
And toxoplasmosis by the way is found
in feline feces which is one reason
why doctors always recommend
that pregnant women
stay away from cat litter.
Other environmental risk factors
include chronic stress
and taking certain drugs, now again,
by themselves, these things do not cause
or even really increase schizophrenia.
It's that coupled with
a genetic predisposition
that's really required.
And again this is what we mean
by the diathesis stress model.